these are the biggest fireworks in  Europe I think they're the best  fireworks in the world they're the best  we've had in London the biggest we've  had in London there are at least three  massive surprises that I can't share  with you otherwise my team won't forgive  me but some really special things uh  tonight they're a reflection on the last  year some really happy events uh  obviously one tragic event uh with the  loss of majesty but it's a really  important way to bring in the new year  we've got the correlation taking place  next year of course with King Charles  the Third but it'll be a message from  London of Love sent to our friends  across Europe and around the world and  it's really important we have a full  recovery after the over two three years  we've had because of the pandemic